字幕: Genta Katakura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
宇宙をもう特別なものにするのは
少しやめませんか？
そういったお話をさせて
頂きたいなと思います
宇宙が そこが特別だから
そこに行けば 自分もなんか
特別になった気がする
そんな風に思って宇宙に行っちゃう人が
ちょっと宇宙の現場に今 増えすぎて
いるんじゃないかなっていうのが
僕が思うことです
５年前 僕はある実験の候補者でした
2013年に「The Mars Society
（火星協会）」という団体が始めた
「模擬火星実験」という実験
その候補者なんですね
クルーの候補者だったんです
で その模擬火星実験というのは
今 写真の方に写ってるこんなような場所 —
ここをですね 地球にある火星
という風に思ってですね
そこが本当の火星だよ
そういう風に思って 実験をする
人が入って 基地に入って生活をする
そんな実験でした
世界でね そういう地球にある火星
というのは いくつかあるんですね
ここが北極のデボン島という島
ここにはクレーターがあります
こういった風にですね
地球にある火星というのは
文明から遠く離れている場所
そして 隔離されていること
そして 探査の目的になるような
クレーターですとか 火口があるような場所
そんなところが
地球にある火星として選ばれます
あと この他にもですね
ハワイ島にあるマウナロア火山ですとか
あるいは ユタ州にあるウィネ砂漠
そういったところが
地球にある火星として有名です
そして そこにはですね
例えば NASAとか The Mars Society とかが
基地を建てて 長期のシミュレーションを
今も実験しているんですね
で 模擬火星実験というので 一応外に —
そこ火星ですから —
外出たときは 宇宙服の偽物なんですけど
そんなのを着なきゃいけない
そんなものなんですが
簡単に言うと火星ごっこです
（笑）
しかもね 本気の 本気の火星ごっこ
いい大人が本気にやる火星ごっこなんですね
先ほど言った The Mars Society というのは
20年くらい前から こうした
シミュレーションの実験をやっていてですね
かなり老舗のような団体ですが
その老舗の団体が
史上最も過酷な場所で
史上最も多様性のあるクルー
そういった触れ込みで
ある公募を始めたんですね
それが僕の参加した公募だったわけです
つまりはですね
本気の中のさらに本気の火星ごっこ
そして ７名のクルーを選考で選ぶ
そんな計画でした
僕はですね その７人のうちのクルーとして
日本人から唯一選ばれました
副隊長もさせてもらったんですけれども
ちょっとね これ自慢なんですけど
実は書類選考に残った
200人ぐらいの候補者の中から
僕がトップで選ばれたんですね
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
選考の担当をしていた責任者からは
こんなことも言われました
他の候補者たち 履歴書とか
あるいはそんなスピーチとかもしますので
そういったものを見ると
もう皆んなもうすごい —
誰選んでいいのってくらい
すごい経歴の人たちばかりが来たと
ただですね 実際に
その訓練を始める その過程になると
特にですね 共同生活なんかさせると
ちょっとがっかりしてしまった
結果になってしまったと
で 僕に関しては
あなたは最初全然目立たなかったのよと
だけど 実際の共同生活で現場に出てみると
そのバランス そしてその現場での実力って
いうのがとても素晴らしかったと
あとはですね やっぱり選考なので
お互い皆ライバルなわけです
そういった中で
個性も強いお互いのライバルの中で
あなたのことだけは
誰も悪い風に言わなかった
そういう風に言われました
まあ なんでですね 僕がこんな
トップで選ばれちゃったのかなっていうのを
自分なりにその理由というか
そういったものをちょっと考えてみると
多分ね 僕は肩の力が一人抜けてたんですね
というのも 僕あんまり
火星に行きたいと思ってないんですね
（笑）
そうなんです
他の皆んな 火星に行きたい人たちの中で
僕だけが思ってなくて
まあね 最近本当に「火星に近い男」なんて
たまに呼んで頂けるんですけど
ちょっと誤解があります
（笑）
僕はですね 専門は建築なんですね
極地の建築 —
「極地で誰かが苦しんで欲しくない」
そういう風に思っています
もちろん火星でも
そういうですね
本来なら人が住めないような場所
そこで 人はどうやって
どんな住まいだったら
そこに留まって暮らしていけるのか？
あるいは そういう場所で
人は何を支えにして生きていけるのか？
そういうことが
僕の一番の関心の中心にあります
だから 僕はこの30代は
そういうことを知りたくて
ずっと 極地といわれる場所に
住んできたわけですね
例えば 北極、南極、エベレスト、富士山頂
そういった場所で住んできました
まあ あの トータルするとですね
日数的には1000日を超えまして
仏教の世界でも 「千日回峰行」というですね
厳しい修業があるわけなんですけど
ぼちぼち悟り開いてもいいかな
という風には思ってるんですけど （笑）
まだちょっとかなという風に思います
僕がですね そういった住まいを
関心としているわけなので
僕がやっぱり見ているのはですね
そこにいる「誰か」なんですね
だから 「どこか」っていうのは
あんまりそんなに問題にしていない
だから 火星っていうのに
そんなに重点がないというか なんですね
そこにいる誰かがすごく大事
なので その さっきの実験中に
「いや 僕あんまり火星
本当は行きたくないんだよね」って
ちょっと言ったら ちょっとね
「じゃお前こっから出て行け」つって
冗談なんだか本気なんだか
なんかそんな感じで言われて
ちょっと「いや 外 火星なんだけど」
みたいな なんかね そんな感じになりました
（笑）
ただですね 振り返ってみると
大昔の 僕らとの宇宙の関係を
考えてみて欲しいんです
大昔というのは 本当に宇宙と
関係のない人なんかいなかったはずです
今みたいに選ばれた人たちの
モノだけじゃなかった
大昔の人たちは例えばですね —
例えば月食、日食
あるいは惑星の動き、太陽の動き
そういったものを観測して
そしてその規則性から
暦 — 今皆さんが使ってる
カレンダーを作ったんです
そういう意味では
僕らのその日常の暮らしというのは
宇宙とは こう 切っても切り離せない
そんな関係に昔からあったんです
ただ 現代の宇宙というのは
ちょっと違います
一部ではあると思うんですが
例えば自分のやりたい
欲求ですとか 利益ですとか
そういったものを中心にしてしまう投資家
あるいは一部の科学者たち
そういった人たちがリードするですね
探査計画とか 色んなものがありますね
そういったものが
中心になってきてしまっている
のではないかなという風に思います
ただその 宇宙という現場で
宇宙を便利にする
あるいは 自分たちの正しさを
宇宙で証明したい
そういったものが 自分の思いの
中心になってしまっていることで
一般の人たちにとっては
なんかちょっと遠くなっちゃったな
そんな宇宙になってはいないかなと思います
とにかくその宇宙をですね
すべて そして自分の手に収めたい
そんなことが宇宙との関わりになって
しまっているのかなという気が少しします
それとですね 印ですね
特別なもの 宇宙ってものを定義して —
これは特別なんだよっていう風に定義して
それに例えば NASAとか JAXAとか
そういった公認の印というか冠を付ける
そして これは宇宙の冠には違いますとか
宇宙の冠に合ってますねとか
そういう風にしてしまうってことが
やっぱりあるんですよね
僕もよく 取材なんかでですね
あなたのこのミッション
いや素晴らしいんですが
これ NASAとどう関係しているんですか？
ってのをね 必ず聞かれるんですよね
まあその The Mars Society って
NASAと関係あるわけじゃないので
ただ まあその 記者さんたちのね
気持ちもすごくよく分かって
多分 読む皆さんもそうなんですけど
なんかこう 「NASA公認」
とかなんか付いてないと
この記事 「何だこれ こいつ怪しい奴だな」
みたいな感じの記事に
なってしまうかなっていう気もします
あの 僕はですね
あんまり目立つ得意なものが
実はあんまりないんですね
小さい頃から ビビりで すごく臆病で
そして よく言えば ですね
「器用貧乏」ってやつですね
ま どれも普通にそこそこできるので
そういう意味ではバランスが
良いとかっていう風には なんですけど
特別なものがあんまりないんです
ただ 運はね
南極越冬隊なんてのは やっぱり
選ばれないと行けないので
そういう意味では 結構大変でしたけど
選ばれたっていう運はあるのかな
なんていうような気がします
ただ 昔から取り柄があまりなかったですが
今の僕には 経験ならあります
経験というのは本当に積み重ねです
そして これからも減るものじゃありません
まあ 南極観測隊 行ってたわけですけど
60年間も南極観測隊
続いているんですよね
60年も続いてる南極観測隊って
スーパーマンみたいな人たち
ばかりじゃないんですよね
例えば 本当に 転勤で仕方なく
南極来ちゃいましたとか
（笑）
あの あとはそうですね
冬の訓練 国内でやるんですけど
「いやー 雪初めて見たんですよね」
みたいな人も本当にいるんですよ
ただ 求められる能力っていうのは
派手さではありません
誰かのために継続していく
そんな力が求められます
南極が終わってから
僕はその後はエベレストに行きました
南極のですね すごい厳しいんですが
やっぱり日々ですね
一つひとつ 丁寧に暮らしていく暮らし
建築の立場からすると
すごい色んな発見があった
だから きっとエベレストに行けば
同じような発見が
また見られるんじゃないかなって思って
期待してエベレストの方に向かいました
ただ がっかりしました
そうじゃなかった
登山家の暮らしっていうのは
すごいギラギラしてたんですね
ま 僕は登山隊のエンジニアとして
ベースキャンプの方にずっといたわけです
ベースキャンプというのはですね
登山家にとってはベースキャンプより先
それは挑戦の場所です
全てを削ぎ落して 挑戦をする
逆にベースキャンプというのは
最後の娑婆なんですね
だから もう我慢しない
もうリラックスしまくり
その人の本当にやりたいこと
エゴがむき出しになるような
そんなギラギラした住環境でした
たまたまですね その年
すごく天候が悪かったんですね
僕はその登山隊に合流する前に
セスナが飛ばなかったもので
これは困ったな ということで
陸路でずっと実は歩いて行ったんです
まあ １週間くらいかけてですね
途中 富士山くらいの峠が
３つくらいあるんですけど
そこをずっと 歩いて行って
で ルクラっていう
本来のスタート場所の飛行場まで
歩いて行ったんです
その道っていうのはですね
本当に観光客なんか全然いない場所で
もう本当に そこの現地の村人たちですね
山の村人たちの生活のための街道だったんです
でも 本当にですね
素敵な場所だったんです
なーんにも無いんですよ
派手さもないし 特別さもないんですけど
決して豊かでもないんですけど
子供たちの目がこうやってキラキラ
自信を持った目をしてるんです
だから僕はその後 ベースキャンプに行って
そのベースキャンプは
結局がっかりしちゃったから
余計にこの道の素晴らしいことばかりが
思い出に残ってしまって
本当に この道のお陰で
天候良かったら行かなかったんですけど —
悪くて良かったなと思ってるんですけど
ネパールが本当に大好きになりました
大きな地震が2015年にあって
その後はですね 特になんですけど
毎年 今でもこの道を
誰かを連れて歩きに行ってます
南極もすごく何もなくて素敵でした
エベレスト — ヒマラヤの山々はですね
神様が住んでる山があるわけです
そして 南極にはこうやって
美しい氷山があるわけです
ただどれもですね 特別な名前が
付いてなかったりするんですよね
もちろん どれが一番高いとか
そういったのも付いてません
山っていうのはですね
この古道の横の山々は
全てヒマラヤなんです
だから 区別もない
で 登ろうっていう山じゃないんですね
それは遠くから眺めて 敬って
そんな存在の山々なんです
で ネパールの人たちは 大昔は
本当にヒマラヤに登ろうとなんて
誰も思い付きもしなかったんですよね
だってそこは 神様か もう本当は
怖い化け物しか住んでない世界だから
「そんな 行かない」とか
そういう感じだったわけです
ところがですね
西洋の考えが その後に入ってきました
で それによって 高さですとか
あるいは難易度ですとか そういったものに
順番ですとか あるいは格式みたいな
そういったものを付けるようになりました
本来だったらですね
そこに競争なんてなかったはずの場所です
だけど 西洋の考え方によって
今 皆さんもご存じのように
やっぱり競争っていうのが
たくさん生まれてしまいました
宇宙の現場っていうのも
今これと同じなんですよね
宇宙っていうものに すごく特別な
なにかこう 冠が付き過ぎている
名前なんかも 勝手にどんどん
付けていくわけなんですね
まぁ ただ確かに 冠が付くと
色んなものが集まってくるんです
人もお金も集まってきます
中には 目立ちたがり屋の人も来るし
だけど 実力のある人も来るし
そうやってですね
価値の足し算みたいなものが始まって
どんどんどんどん こう宇宙が
動き出していくんですね
で 現代では SNSなんかも
そのスピードを速めたりします
まあ 僕はですね
挑戦するっていう気持ちを
決して僕は否定しようとは
思っていないんです
好奇心、挑戦をする、想像力っていうのは
僕ら人間に与えられた
最高の乗り物だと思っています
大昔は僕ら — 大昔じゃないですね —
子供の頃は 僕ら 本当に
紙飛行機ひとつあれば
こうやって 宇宙まで
飛んで行けたじゃないですか
ね だからそういうのは
やっぱり想像力の力だと思うし
大昔だって やめとけって言われてても
こっそりね もう行きたくて行きたくて
こっそり登った人だってね
いたはずなんですよ ヒマラヤだって
で そういった人たちだけじゃなくて
今の時代にだって
そういう土地の歴史であるとか
場所、色んなものに 畏敬の念 —
そういうものを持った冒険家たちが
今でもちゃんといるわけです
で やっぱりそういう冒険家の背中をね
僕は見てると なんかやっぱり
「ああ良いなこの背中 美しいな」
っていうのをいつも思ったりしてます
まあ 暮らすとか生きていく
っていうことっていうのは
やっぱり 日常なんですよね
で その日常の世界の中に
特別な冠っていうものを持ち込んじゃうと
まあこりゃ大変なわけです
暮らしていく — 「日常」というのは
そこにしかいない誰か —
その人と一緒に生きていくことなのに
特別な冠がそこに入ってしまうと
いつも ここではないどこかばかりに
目が行ってしまうわけです
そうすると 自分の人間の自惚れとか
自意識だとか あるいは無関心さ
そういったものが 自覚の無い中で
むき出しになっちゃうんです
僕が体験してきた
火星ごっこの暮らしというのは
まさにそんな形でした
僕はですね ギラギラした人たちじゃなくて
キラキラした目をした子供たち —
こういう子供たちですね —
あるいは 地味でもいい
普通に色んなことを続けられる人が来る時代
そういう宇宙の時代が
早く来て欲しいなぁという風に思っています
だから 今日皆さんに
お願いしたいことが ひとつあります
宇宙を特別なものと
だから 自分たちには関係のない場所
そういう風に思うのはやめてですね
皆さんがいつも誰かのために
普通に続けていること
それを宇宙の世界の中に
ぜひ持ち込んで欲しいんですね
そうすれば 宇宙の暮らしというのは
きっと素敵なものになるはずです
経験者の役割というのは
新しい人たちをナビゲートすることだと
僕は南極である先輩に教わりました
そして「 安全もそうだけど
楽しむことも忘れないでね」
という風に言われました
僕はナビゲートしますので
是非皆さん 宇宙を一緒に考えましょう
ありがとうございました
（拍手）